dans notre grande enquête toujours est
ce que le français serviable est ce que
le français va accepter de porter une
jeune dame comme 80 lary qui fait
semblant de s'être foulé la cheville
est-ce qu'il va la porter jusqu'à sa
voiture la question est posée et bien
entendu dans l'ombre il y à jacques
legras qui veille
regardez bien ce sketch de la caméra
cachée tourner ces jours ci dans paris
là je prends pas mon cas c'est non et
c'est un jeu par saleh dans ma voiture
aulas
oui oui
c'est la quête de la vérité
c
et toi
je peux vous dire en particulier n'ont
pas stérile
une main portrait elle m'a demandé de
lui apporter comme ça d' effet je me
suis retrouvé sans mon portefeuille
vous avez toujours votre portefeuille
oui c'est sûr vous en assurer
à
mais qu'est ce que j'ai dit je dis
attention parce que quelqu'un toujours
les mêmes
collet laffon
ce départ manqué mais j'avais une partie
fallu quand même pas qu'on sait jamais
et d'avoir
ah ouais ouais on part dans les bras
à converger collector
pourquoi
j'ai plus
eh bien vous le voyez tous les hommes
acceptent de porter café alary mais tout
ça repose à terre quand on est l'autre
leur portefeuille en particulier parce
que les allemands fin trait comme ça et
peut donc y retrouver mon porteur
depuis toujours oui je vous êtes sûrs
c'est certain mais c'était pour la
caméra cachée vous savez j'ai filmé pour
la gamme et radiations
je peux vous dire qu'on veut dire un mot
parce que rien
hier elle m'a fait la même chose je me
suis retrouvé sans mon portefeuille
alors moi je vous conseille de la
laisser m oui hein si je me suis
retrouvé sans mon pas vous avez votre
portefeuille toujours un
oui vous avez de la chance parce qu'il
ya moi j'aime bien avant et oui mais il
est à vous mais demandez vous pas fait
aussi parfois par mois je vous connais
et puis quand j'ai fini de vous fier
j'avais plus mon portefeuille allez
prouver quelque chose
non mais vous verrez bien je sais qu'il
est nécessaire c'est certain pour les
femmes le conflit ossète lui apporter
madame comme ça tranquillement galopante
et pas désagréable
oui
une chose en particulier parce que elle
m'a fait une cour hier je me suis
retrouvé sur mon portefeuille
en particulier la même chose et vous
avez tout vu
c'est son problème
c
eric un oui massif
vous dire un moment particulier parce
qu'il y a
et puis je me suis informé sans mon
portefeuille
le problème n'est portée jacques n'osera
pas ça c'est mieux si vous pouviez me
porter
je suis comme ça dans la vie aussi mais
si j'ai des bons points séparent et la
voiture est là justement pour une tente
et sous préfets
mais bon
les matous réponse ça c'est préventif
est très gentil
avait lieu en france à 16
non non vous les jeux des jouets
qu'est ce que la rencontre ne suis pas
ici
ces hommes étaient prêts et pas vraiment
parce que celui très très dur de me
porter je fais un bon point quand même
d'un verre ça peut se faire mais c'est
difficile de même vous l'avais cru quand
elle est venue dans sa vie ce jeudi
parce que porter jacques legras voyez
vous n'allez pas y arriver aussi
oui on n'a pas pu trouver une panthère
rose c'est dommage on en a trouvé une
panthère mouchetés qui appartient à
monsieur le sourd qui qui ont l'habitude
de prêter de louer des animaux pour le
cinéma c'est d'une panthère magnifique
superbe et jacques legras la tenue en
laisse chaque le graal à tenir en laisse
et voulant toujours vérifier la bonne
volonté des passants il a demandé à des
passants de lui garder sa panthère sous
prétexte qu'il doit rentrer chez un
commerçant et que vous savez on ne peut
pas rentrer chez des commerçants avec
des animaux alors bien entendu pour que
la surprise la plus grande la panthère
est un peu caché sous un porche et puis
pour éviter aussi des attroupements des
curieux parce que j'avais beaucoup de
curieux cantons seront menées dans la
pente avec la panthère dans paris alors
voici donc tournés en caméra cachée vous
allez regarder maintenant la réaction
des passants à qui jacques legras
demande de lui garder ça pour faire le
plus difficile c'est la mise en place de
la panthère loin des regards curieux
bien entendu les propriétaires de la
panthère messieurs lesourd ont une
double less qui leur permet de retenir
la panthère si elle voulait bondir en
avant on ne sait jamais
monsieur ça vous ennuie pas une seconde
de tenir mon animal parce qu'il
n'accepte pas les animaux
j'en ai pas deux minutes c'est parce que
c'est pour mon animal de me tenir parce
que je vais où je vais vous dire ou pas
reste là reste d'amour
ça vous ennuie pas de tenir le monde
animal j'en ai pour deux minutes j'en ai
bien plus longtemps
oui c'est mon chien bien sûr non
oui c'est un chat et quel gros chat et
urbain 84 en france
sur un service monsieur parce qu'il
n'accepte pas les animaux là la
pâtisserie j'en ai pour deux minutes
mais pas que jean dujardin pour trouver
un accord pour deux minutes là c'est
parce qu'ils n'acceptent pas les animaux
du tout et vous les malades non mais
écoutez je faisais crise n'est pas là
monsieur je peux vous demander un
service s'il vous plaît jolie peau de
deux minutes parce qu'il n'accepte pas
les animaux dans le dans la pâtisserie
si vous voulez me dire j'en ai trop pour
deux minutes ça va pas tarder ça
n'allait pas je n'ai pas pour après la
réaction des hommes voici celle des
femmes
madame je vous demander un service parce
que je sois allé à la pâtisserie lamy
lui n'accepte pas les animaux ça vous
ennuie pas la garde et deux minutes là
elle est très très mignonne j'en ai pour
deux minutes pour aller chercher elle
est très gentille
non mais non on joue au piano expliquait
alors que c'était pour atteindre jeudi
cinéma j'en ai pour deux minutes
oui mais je sais juste que je veux juste
à dire où elle peut être magnifique elle
est belle à la il n'accepte pas les
animaux à la pâtisserie ça vous ennuie
pas j'en ai j'en ai pas j'en ai pour
deux 2 2 minutes ça vous ennuie pas je
vous expliquais c'est pour la caméra
vous expliquer ces points mais ne riez
pas passer pour une émission d très
gentille elle est à dire oui elle est
adorable
oui c'est souboz
elle est très mignonne avait lancé c'est
pour être pour une émission disant au
revoir à la panthère échanges d'animal
histoire de voir si les passants ont
plus ou moins peur d'un petit animal
qu'est ce que tu es un jacques legras en
laisse vous avez bien vu c'est un rat
oui vous ennuierez pas de le garder
parce que je dois aller chez le à la
boulangerie et puis ils ne veulent pas
et ne veulent pas d'animaux
ah non non pas ce que je fais juste là y
retourne
j'en ai déjà vu ça ça vous en ai pas
regardé mon tir alors beaucoup
d'événements vous voulez pas regarder
voulait pas garder mon gira mais sinon
oui c'était pour antenne de wii vous
aviez pas dit il au real est ou doit il
aurait il serait resté pour une demie a
pas du tout non non non non et tout
frais tout chaud
j'ai eu il faut que j'aille là les faux
jags comment à la pâtisserie mais ils
veulent pas d'animaux ça veut dire si ça
vous ennuie pas de me garder n'est pas
prometteur au jour j'en ai pour j'en ai
pour 5 10 minutes pas plus ça vous
ennuie pas trop sinon ça ne vous fait
pas peur
cette huile est très mignon oui cet
accord donnerait cette blague a cessé
pour la l'émission d'antenne de ses
rivaux jeudi cinéma
nous étions film et pour ça je m'arrête
je vous remercie de russie oui oui c'est
bien parce qu'en version on va voir ça
je dis jeudi prochain
et une caméra cachée bien sûr et vous
avez en hiver quand on le peut on
tourner à l'intérieur parce qu il fait
meilleur et que les gens restent plus
facilement avec nous alors au centre
beaugrenelle il y a deux escaliers
roulants
il y en a un qui monte et il y en a un
qui descendent les frères oui comme les
frères alors si on bouche le haut
quand les gens sont engagés et si on
bouge de bas bien les gens sont obligés
de faire un circuit quoi de monte et
descend ce sont des gens qui ont des bas
des eaux néo et des baraquements
comme je le disais c'est ce qu'on a fait
au centre le mot grenelle avec la
complicité de la direction que nous
remercions ici
voici les les escaliers roulants piégée
tout d'abord un américain à paris est
pris au piège d'une autre escalier
roulant en hausse et des affaires net et
cyril diar est intraitable
comment ça monsieur commencent à réviser
les shoots en pâte
pascaline à bord en temps
et en bas jacques legras va bloquer à
son tour c'est l'heure
oui c'est long terme est là
america's et d'obéissance oublié de
remonter ça remonte
et comme macarthur il a dit à jacques
legras je reviendrai et il revient et
daniel roth cas va continuer à
accompagner ainsi d'autres clients pour
recueillir leurs impressions
je suis l'axé mais permet là où a
commencé à la ronde et sans dépendre des
stériles ans
apparemment là
ça
rossi part dans le ciel ça fait une
petite forme malgré ben oui
qui a le temps de se promener
aux commandeurs plus de sorties ciné
quoi donc
bah oui c'est franchement que c'est pas
des escaliers roulants
ouais
enfin il nous a mis dedans au oui mais
non mais non mais non je fais venir une
jeune fille qui sort des sentiers je
vois chez vous
je demande pas mieux
bon ben on va essayer encore mais alors
vraiment
ah oui ça c'est sûr
ah oui ça vous avez c'est bien français
mais les français ça souvent le sens de
l'humour est voué à la roue mais si
c'est terminé
oui bel optimisme cet exode les
vendredis par mois
maintenant ma passion oui
et il ya lire cliente qui m'ont kata 4
pour mieux se casser le nez en eau
à
qu'est-ce-qui sa valeur des mots d'amour
c'est tellement grossier mais la
mauvaise vie et en même temps et qui se
précipitent vous retrouver jacques
legras maintenance à l'eau
voici maintenant il va vous laisser
passer ici ça permet maintenant avec
google
tout à l'heure c'était ouvert ici et
c'était fermé là haut est maintenant
c'est le contraire c'est sûr tout l'été
on veut pas sortir des nao alors oui
c'est la récession c'est sûr nous sommes
toujours emballé
allez non non non
moyen
arrivé en bas se terminera mais je ne
suis pas dans un bon jour mais plus
grave encore
si vite et si on va essayer de descendre
a raconté à la jambe dans la peinture
venez
venez on va demander à la junte de
juillet comment madame est ennuyé elle
voudrait sortir du mans c'est là où
maintenant dédié musicale et un volet
bien c'est pas possible la vallée
simpliste du sport madame line à paris
je suis rentré je t'aime annales de
devenir la femme n'est pas c'est
ridicule
nous exigeons d'eux c'est ici que de
deux ans maintenant madame venez je vais
me dire ce sont là pour la sélection
française pour antenne 2 6 pour la
caméra cachée
cinéma vérité bien oui dans la première
émission de jeudi cinéma nous avions
essayé de faire un parallèle vous le
savez entre un gag du film de jacques
tati mon angle et les réactions des gens
de la rue filmée par une caméra cachée
savait pas mal marché d'ailleurs alors
là nous aurions bien voulu pour leur
faire le gag du film de corniaud le gars
qu'on va au début du film où la voiture
vous savez se déglingue au moindre choc
malheureusement antennes de nous n'avons
pas les moyens de faire mes gags aussi
somptueux alors nous sommes contentés de
deux trucs et simplement un taxi un faux
taxi qui est conduit par jacques legras
et dont toutes les poignées de porte
ce reste dans la main quand on tire
dessus alors quelles vont être les
réactions des gens de la rue avec ce
taxi un peu spéciale de monsieur jacques
legras regardez vous allez voir
des fêtes oui je sais pas ce qui se
passe là à rêver c'est la porte qui doit
être c'est pas que doivent presser alors
maintenant on va plutôt rire il a passé
par d'autres tirs ici
aval à passer le taux pour l'autre côté
vous m'avez vous m'avez arracher les 37
costaud 1
heureusement moi je vous expliquerai
j'allais dire oui peut-être bien non
lors les imams pour étonner à la
batterie si vous voulez ouvrir la porte
là je vais avoir un effet ça fait de
doter les costauds à massieux voyez les
brutes briner à s'y intéresser
elle est comme ça oui fallait la prendre
mais pas au bout cette foutue c'est ici
chez vous savez vous allez vous il va
s'appeler ya pas d ouvrir un poste
normal on va sombrer celle ci l'a plutôt
la nounou vraie celle là la merci mag
est ce qui se passe alors regardez sont
posés tout havel tiennent elles tiennent
mal là où elles sont arrachés et a pas
de montre vie là bas vous allécher
pourquoi c'était c'était pour vous cette
voiture sepsi enfin oui et non c'était
assez fait pour aujourd'hui cinéma vous
savez bon je vis ici débat oui
ouvrez ouvrez celle ci il avait arraché
à la houle avait arraché la pole et non
j'ai rien lâché du tour si elles sont
fixées montée devant monter le français
je pousse à enlever ça derrière aussi
ah oui vous avez abîmé la voiture la
branche est pas abîmer vous qu'est ce
que vous avez à la mer vous l'avez
remarqué deux catégories chez les
clients de jacques legras tout d'abord
les gens très honnête qui rendait
immédiatement la poignée à son
propriétaire
mais
je vous la donne
oui merci oui et cas c est ce que vous
avez appelé vaquera baballe monte à côté
de moi alors coincé deuxième catégorie
les bricoleurs section si vous l'avez
cas c'est aussi celle là alors moi je
les casser bah oui moi je les cafés
sa taille est en émoi ce n'est rien à
côté de moi ça fait rien
à
ah bon vous prisé drôlement costaud on
est dedans
thierry lhermitte qui a interprété le
film les ripoux que vous connaissez qui
triomphent toujours d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il est toujours là prise ce jour film
de claude zidi avec philippe noiret et
notre notre caméra cachée de ce soir
pourrait s'intituler le rythme car
jacques legras joue vraiment un flic
ripoux jusqu'à la moelle puisqu'ils
demandent de l'argent pour pour de vote
donnaient renseignements dans la rue
c'est pour vous dire alors quelle va
être la réaction des passants est ce
qu'ils vont payer
il ya catherine alary qui amorce la
situation le renseignement vous demander
de le france de prendre le renseignement
c'est bouclé et oui on a des frais
les indiens de son mouvement mais on
savait mais moi j'ai mon parti à payer
si l'on sait jouer une pièce givet alors
vous prenez oui vous prend de monter
vous prenez la deuxième a commenté le
groupe français
oui comment ces flics on ça non moi je
le fais depuis pas mal de temps déjà
comment j'ai pas de four net à 201 et
vos liens renseignements la wii les
flics sont comme ça non moi moi
seulement les collègues le font pas ça
mes collègues ne le font pas eux il y en
a je les connais qui donne des
renseignements gratuits vous savez les
rats qui donne des renseignements il y
aller à fond
ah oui elle a abandonné alors vous venez
de francs que je vous le dis nous c'est
pourquoi les propos oui
voilà cinq francs joueurs jouant de
francs alors franklin delano roosevelt
fusillait tu me prends pour le
renseignement
moi oui je peux payer les renseignements
personnellement c'est pour moi c'est
parce que j'ai les frais de parking vous
voyez les frais d'essence les frais
d'essence les frais d'essence et tout ça
vous comprenez vous prenez non on va
ces bonheurs moi je connais son aile
farid hamache commodore le fameux
doucement
bénévolement je l'accompagné jusqu'à ce
genre vous pouvez de me donner 200 pour
elle voilà mais ce jeu là c'est quand
même
c'est tout à fait personnel voilà
mais si c'est pour moi non le
renseignement c'est pour le
renseignement pour savons tous les
champs elysées je peux vous dire on
faisait des missions pour la télévision
française pour antenne 2 nous étions
film est actuellement vous c'est je
remercie
voilà c'est ça essentiellement nous
mener de front
deux sens entre le renseignement
mais c'est parce qu'on a on a des
faibles à la vôtre à meerab
comment
go oui oui mais je vous demandais si
vous demandez un renseignement ou le
mans d2 je le prends dans ces zones
renseignements mais s'appuyer parce que
j'ai des frais alors bonnet g
je les ferai une partie j'ai ma voiture
là et vous mettre des sous dans le parti
bon tout ça alors comment sur son but
contre commis oui je m'en des deux
français trouvez comment oui
ah non c'est moi personnellement je peux
payer moins personnellement si vous avez
de france vous ne levez le renseignement
si c'est mon droit si vous voulez vous
me donnez de francs avait pas problème
non non moi je moi je moi
personnellement suzhou donneront des
renseignements personnels
soudain deux ans voulait pas le savoir
bon voila vous me donnez pas de francs
est tous un peu loin voulait un
renseignement
oui rires potts et de 2 francs
j'appelais mon poste de 200 le
renseignement avec
parce que c'est obligé vous comprenez
moi qui en veux à mon avis c'est pas ça
mais j'ai beaucoup de frais alors je
suis obligé de j'ai pris ma voiture et
pour le parking c'est cette pratique
voyez vous voulez alors d'euros ce poste
a pour la poste la poste ces deux francs
de plus pour la bourse aux livres les
rues largement garner est pas problème
et pour la poste s'est couché
de renseignements non écoutez je vous
expliquer je vais vous donner le
renseignement deux francs pour le
renseignement il
pas que
hier et je manque de sens parce que
mal de ce fait sûrement
je remercie c'est la première à gauche
l'avenue montaigne que la iberia oui je
vous demandais volet l'enseignement et
vous demander deux français tués la dir
font toujours de personnel parce que
j'aime seulement la voiture
quant au casting polonais moi vous savez
des services quelque part et on connait
pas la décision plaisir trouver
quelqu'un qui peut l'aider
évidemment c'est ça patine iman bowie
l'avenue montaigne oui c'était c'est
assez simple dans le renseignement
vous êtes ensemble alors je vous demande
et 200 pour le
parce que les tabous c'est ça ça fait 2
c de francs par personne
une raison à ce lancement je veux savoir
oui derrière vous l'avez noté jean
ferrat je vous ferai un prix alors je
vous fais un peu tard sont allemands
l'ont eyed peas à vannes je ne pouvais
pas
quand on va chez moi alors je vous
renvoie de francs n'ont joué hier
c'était pour la caméra cachée l'émission
de télévision